welcome back cameras in this video we're
gonna build a 1x1 scale replica of my
hometown in 24 hours we have dozens of
builders here and we have Pippen how's
it going this is his channel and he is
currently building a 1x1 scale replica
of the world and since he is building
the entire world in Minecraft while he's
building my hometown we thought we would
hang out with them and you don't record
it and do some dumb stuff it's a
pleasure
this right here is capital building this
right here is the outline for the
building and this is the garden and the
trees around it but we're not stopping
there with just this building we're
building the entire city all of this in
Minecraft in 24 hours
or at least we're gonna try how do we
start I've never built a city of
Minecraft what do we do so it ends up
being 17 meters - sort of this angular
roof area which is gonna be fun to build
oh one meter is one block oh then that's
em 15 16 17 blocks tall there I did it
are you happy Pippen yeah that was great
dude it's kind of white so we're gonna
use courts for this building it which
sides the front which side is the front
that's actually really good question but
here you're building the world wait is
this really the shape of it yeah it's so
grossly unsymmetrical why is the
building shaped like this why don't we
just look for the front door wait
there's a door that has to be it perfect
okay so we have the walls it's starting
to take shape like this building as you
guys concede the server froze we've got
ourselves a place to work here for the
roof I'm trapped inside hey I want
verbal confirmation we are building our
city in Minecraft Chris will you stop
being dumb for five seconds I'll try
Carl will you stop being dumb for five
seconds yes sir Chandler you just keep
being Chandler you're doing great from
up there it looks like a Yankee with no
broom oh I'm working on it I'm working
on it okay I'm not gonna lie I probably
did most of this building the buildings
starting to take shape
it's starting to look like our Capitol
building this still Fino guy is killing
it he's a great builder yeah I taught
him everything I know what have you done
for this project this man's dancing be
putting it all on the line
well you guys what line the conga line
hey there it is it's maybe the hardest
thing I've ever done in my life all
right and words we out here doing it we
build it don't we man and as you guys
can see this capital building is coming
along very nicely this project is
starting to make a lot of sense like I
see how you guys do it it's hard and
time-consuming but it's definitely
possible
so Pippin now that I've seen you build
this I kind of want to see New York
right because you're building the entire
world you've already built New York can
you show us around it yeah we're gonna
teleport there in three two one oh all
right
whoa well it's taken a couple months
they do these huge time streams of it
it's just it looks amazing I'm surprised
this took months not years so I'm
currently in New York boys just walking
in the middle of the street haha thank
you I'm glad you did that it's like I'm
actually there I think this is from this
clip and when we ate that cheap pizza
for those of you that don't know we ate
a $70,000 golden pizza Wow did you know
that New York had the two Nintendo Wiis
monuments these are the Nintendo Wii
monuments gotcha
these are for you know remembering how
great the Wii was yes you know what I
can't afford a New York apartment so I'm
gonna claim this one this is the New
York Stock Exchange Chris yeah this is
like I guess Wall Street I'll take three
Walmart three Mario get them for you
hold on uh-oh it's a bad day on the
stock market you're getting cold
but then Eli must tweeted something and
Morgan goes yeah we have many years
maybe decades ahead of us of world
minecraft all right he hit us at the
decade what if Microsoft just like yeah
we're done with Minecraft and like 20
years and you're just like no set up the
whole thing locally and people still be
able to play Minecraft after hearing
about New York I I wanna I want to see
this in action you ready to go build
North Carolina yeah let's just crank it
let's do it everyone start building okay
so that's how you communicate with
everyone
[Music]
okay guys it's the middle of the night
leapin Delfino here are going to
orchestrate this little tour we're like
what if we you guys don't like a fourth
of the way into building yeah six hours
okay yeah we're six hours in let's look
at how beautiful the Capitol is now now
that we are about six hours in it looks
much better than what it did all the
buildings all around it the street is
all laid out look at all these buildings
and I'm just walking down a street in a
city look at this this is six hours into
them starting it was completely empty
how many builders do you guys have like
on average online we've had about thirty
thirty builders have done all of this in
six hours that's insane look how tall
this is this is a fourth of the way in I
can't imagine what its gonna look like
24 hours in
[Applause]
so this is 18 hours in there 3/4 of the
way done
this is Braden early in the morning and
I still see a lot of builders that I saw
last night the middle of the night it
looks really good I mean I really didn't
know exactly how far 30 builders he
could get in 24 hours but we're starting
to see the end effects of it and the
transformation is just incredible this
really is like a full city this is
outrageous yeah yeah I mean we got
really far I don't even know how far
people got because they're just keep
stretching outward and out we're now and
outward look at the mini-map just
straight up it looks like a real map we
still have four hours to sort of clean
everything up here yeah you guys are
only like it well I guessed about like
3/4 of the way the American flag is made
of TNT
[Music]
and the 24 hours is finished thank you
everybody here that spent all this time
building snowmobile 2004
yes snowmobile but nein nein nein nein
nein tell us very stake sup 13 all world
class legendary builders whoo hey what
about me
you guys saw tons of time-lapse footage
this is insane just look at that
mini-map right there literally looks
like you were break up into groups and
let's go explore the new town you know
what's the point of even living in the
real world when you can just live on
Minecraft I really stand by Carl look at
this view right here wow this track
traffic symbols now I'm the traffic
light just don't move the rest of the
video just stay there
bye Jimmy bye Carl have fun getting a
traffic light snowmobile you better not
run this red light stop running it stop
oh yeah this isn't a stage oh yeah look
at it this is the campus of NC State
University and Chris almost went to this
college I wouldn't Community College
instead Chris give us a tour of the
campus
you would have been in this classroom
learning about how to plant things come
on in see look at all this grass they
plant it you guys know how everytime we
go downtown and Raleigh you see that
giant evil BB&T building mm-hmm there it
is it literally looks like an evil
corporation owns this building
and the funny thing is this is exactly
what it looks like and realized like
this is spot-on check it out dude do you
know who built this one who built by
Carl nope this was made by mr. worse
towhen and it took him nine hours to do
it he built this for nine hours also I
want to know what this is what is this
thing yeah I was trying to figure it out
all night I was like what are those red
balloons you guys are making yeah here
let me fix the sign it says mischievous
gaming channel but what it should say is
subscribe to mr. beast gaming oh hey fun
fact that Convention Center is where I
saw a phantom power weekend place where
did we go for that one concert the same
place oh wait take me to it yeah we went
to the Dirty Heads concert at it Chris
got tickets to Dirty Heads concert and I
just can't I didn't even know what it
was and I ended up leaving early we left
early due to the thunderstorm that
happened right I left early because the
music tastes yo I remember this crane
Chris never seen this last time really
to be fair a lot of cranes do look alike
but this crane I could never forget this
crane
this is the crane this is what living in
Raleigh gets you this is probably like 2
grand a month this uh this little square
which building actually was the hardest
ability the German guy said that it took
nine hours that was probably the record
for any individual building this is the
tallest building in Raleigh right here
oh because it has this little pole here
they're like the same height and they're
like okay here let's just add some glass
to the top so it could be ten feet
taller hey you know they got it done
look at that oh my gosh it's not indeed
good hey do a very happy reverse f5 it
looks like we're all superheroes fine so
as you guys saw we just built a lot of a
city in 24 hours but there are a lot of
places in the world there are so many
places in the world none of us can ever
fathom just how many places in the world
there are Pippen is not gonna stop until
he builds the entire war
and minecraft and if you want to help
him go to his channel will be linked in
description if you help him build
buildings in his skill replica of the
world hope credit you with the sign
thank you guys for watching see you in
the next video subscribe bye